[Musica]
benvenuti a c'è posta per te quella di
oggi è la storia di chiara chiara è una
ragazza molto famosa occhiata è stata un
ragazzo questo un ragazzo si chiamava
federico la loro storia è una storia è
fatta di storie di vista ma soprattutto
una storia a distanza e come tutti
sappiamo le storie a distanza causa non
molta sofferenza in collegamento da los
angeles chiara ferragni convenuta chiara
fatti pure è chiesto ma senti maria
hanno leggermente parlare l'italiano
perché qua nessuno ti capisce forse
neanche la grazie se conta sistema
lacrime capello mazzoletti fedenrico in
arte fede ha chiamato la redazione e ha
detto che voleva scrivere una lettera
perché pensava fosse l'unico modo per
riuscire a via verde chiaro quello che
non ti aveva mai detto
questa è la lettera che gli ha scritto
tabellone mio non vuoi capire quanto
manchi quando siamo lontani
mi manca tutto di te
mi mancano i backstage e vissuti del
backstage del video dei rifiuti delle
foto che non si associa mi manca
decidere insieme quali futuri camera per
poi finire a pubblicare la stessa perché
non abbiamo sparti di guardarvi tutte
essendo di paia di jeans cambia location
mi manda tutti in photoshop fa sembrava
rino mele foto senza andare in palestra
mi manca chiamate il territorio alle 4
del mattino pertanto arci 2 gavioli
simboli del nostro amore eterno finché
dura
sì perché noi non sappiamo se questa
nostra storia troverà che ogni cosa che
facciamo fa gossip 2000 ci potrà
dividere
volevo che tu sapessi carico di tali dei
così tanto criticate perché sono
perfette che passerà il 9 a giocarsi
volevo che tu sapessi mettiamo anche se
ha fatto il marcio del mio album e
quando parli inglese in dieci di ridotto
e che tuo messaggio gioca ed è veramente
troppo vago milano e notte se non
dormirà rispetto di sognare teatro punta
qui sul mio fianco preferito il tuo tuo
patatone fede chiamarli store pays de
conno sono qui perché chiara c'è ed è
stato capito
ciao a tutti ciao maria ciao raviolone
ti è piaciuta alla lettera per fatto
piangere tantissimo meeeting se il mio
pacchetto vale comunque c'era sorprese
anche per te scritto la lettera anch'io
e adesso telelecco sei pronta vaiolo
raviolo della mia vita da quando ti
vista la prima volta ho capito dei venti
centimetri di altezza che ci separano
non era la mia in tecnico fronte al
nostro amore infatti di foto in piedi ne
facciamo pochissime e quando le facciamo
o fondo nella sabbia fino a quando
sentiamo altri vari ponti faccio mettere
rialzi sotto le scarpe idea dovrebbe
essere così protettivo nei confronti
gioco primi vedete nelle foto perché
anche se fai gesta e le tasse un
passatore gelosone adoro quando mi metti
le dita nel naso è vero quando mi dice
che l'inizio tante sono belle anche se
tutto il mondo dice che fanno cagare
e davvero quando dici che una prima
pronuncia solo perché non capisce
l'inglese
e allora cosa ci facciamo fare le foto
mentre fingeva di dormire se abbiamo un
gigante col folletto ovviamente farebbe
sede
e allora cosa ti chiedo di farmi una
foto e mi far ethereal sei proprio un
burlone amore mio non avrei mai pensato
che un giorno avrebbe tutto i miei
italiani dei treni american days e non
avere in mente il fatto che amore di
pace seri cretini e al punto i capelli
crisi forio dietro l'orecchio
sì questo in gravi o le del cuore tenero
ricordo ancora quel giorno da v seguito
detto se devi essere tamarro meglio
essere eccessivamente tamarro non avevo
mai dato un consiglio così preziosa
nessuno cus vicino nella notte del tuo
telefono e promettimi di essere per
sempre il mio patatino effettivamente
tamarro dal cuore di raviolo cinese come
quelli che mangiava sempre a los angeles
non ti ho mai detto ma se l'apostrofo
rosa tra le parole ai guy hands mating
di oggi della via cabina armadio tua la
viola innamorata
chiaro mi ha fatto piangere guida dello
scherzo delle iene o chiediamoci caldo
va ai ravioli
i ragazzi avete fatto nazionale domani
sappiamo che li ripete quindi aspettiamo
con ansia i mostri un testo e ringrazio
tutti per avermi seguito serie che ci
torni video iscrivetevi al khadar e
servizio su tutti i gatti social
snapshots in stata musicali e cristo c'è
posta per te alla prossima puntata
[Musica]